ما نطلق الحكم سافرته معلنا فوزه تشيلي
بالمركز الثالث في المونديال الذي
استضافته عام 62 حتى اختلطت دموع الفرح
بالحزن
فما سبب ذلك عام 56 فازت تشيل المتواضعه
بشرف استضافه كاس العالم متفوقه على
الارجنتين العملاقه بعدما تمكن رئيس اتحاد
الكره من اقناع الفيفا في كلمه قال فيها
لا نملك شيئا ولكن نريد تنظيم المونديال
لتحسين احوالنا الاقتصاديه ورغم ان زلزله
بقوه 9 درجات ونصف على مقياس ريختار ضرب
البلاد قبل عامين على مونديال 62 الا ان
تشيلي اصرت على الاستضافه فقد كانت فرصه
حقيقيه لها لنسيان مشاهد الموت والدمار
لكن الاقدار اختارت لصاحب الفضل في ذلك
كارلوس دبور ان يفارق الحياه قبل مونديال
بحوالي شهر ولا يكون شاهدا على الفصل
الاخير من القصه العظيمه التي جرس حياته
بكتابتها